this is an HR representative recorded
this Tick Tock video as I guess a
warning apparently to right Wingers who
post about their views publicly and she
just kind of is warning us and uh
let's just watch it watch
I'm a recruiter It's a Small Small
industry smaller than you'd think same
with HR so if you're looking for a job
or maybe trying to keep a job
maybe just maybe
think about what you're putting on
social media
again Freedom Fighters I know you're not
really big with stats and you know facts
aren't your thing you know but what I
can tell you what is a fact
Reuters talk and recruiters like the
majority of Canada don't agree with you
do you know what that means do you have
any guesses any guesses would that means
that means that means
if you need a job you might not get one
if you want to keep a job you might not
get to do that
and
you know what else they charge good at
documentation
you know what that means you want to be
enough
we document it we give you a couple
tries then what do we do we terminate
you with cause if we're so lucky
if not we give you the minimum Allowed
by law
either way best of luck to you
recruiters are watching HR is watching
everywhere and we hate you we hate you
so much and you think we can't do
anything
[Music]
we have
to always remember that doesn't matter
if there's a [ __ ] man at the top of
your HR department
run by women and it's run by Angry women
just just like okay me
you don't want you to wear this I'm so
so glad I got that I'm like just
this is this is like this is like if if
nurse ratchet was your bitter drunk aunt
it's just the worst combination of I
mean do you I guess she doesn't realize
but you
it you're viscerally repulsive and
unappealing in every way to everyone
like
and I guess she doesn't realize that
about me because one of the
prerequisites to be something like that
is you have to have no self-awareness
whatsoever
that first of all Telltale sign of
self-awareness or lack thereof is when
you're talking to uh you know the the
phone and you have the screen that close
to your face
and you just know that that's what she
does to people in real life too can you
imagine that
she's up that close in your face talking
to you
you have to smell the stale uh white
wine on her breath
it you know you see that and you think
well that's uh okay that's a bitter
lonely cat lady
you know childless husbandless and
there's a chance of that but there's
also very you know it's like a lot of
these people are married can you imagine
being married to that I would just I'd
have to move to Siberia I don't think
there's any
there's no way to endure it
but what you have to realize is that
corporate HR departments it's actually
it's it's it's good that she decided to
post this
corporate HR departments are full of
people like this
maybe not quite that
extreme or that you know kind of openly
blatantly repulsive but full of people
like this
in the sense of being totally drunk on
the little bit of power that they have
okay they have a little bit then this
you find this in bureaucracies all over
bureaucracies and
um
big corporations are all bureaucracies
too and in effect people that work at
these HR departments these major
companies are in effect bureaucrats
really glorified
um and and this is what you find just a
bunch of people who are given this
little sliver of power it's like not
that much but it's a little bit
and they have they have little ways and
sometimes not so little ways that they
can make your life difficult and they
just love doing it they whatever they
can do whatever a small amount of power
you give to them they become like she's
an actual super villain she's this is
what it's a kind of video you would see
a super villain in a comic book movie
record like the only thing that was
missing was and I was expecting it
honestly was the maniacal laughter which
usually that's the kind of thing you see
in movies all the time where the villain
comes up with this evil plan and then
laughs about it and it's like you never
see people do that in real life even the
most evil people but um I was I was
expecting it there the kind of Joker
cackle at the end
she's become a super villain because of
a little power that she got from the HR
department
but here's the great thing here's the
the happy ending to that is that she she
Begins the video by saying be very
careful what you put on social media
well she probably should have taken her
own advice because apparently now her
employer has been made aware of this
video and is looking into it and uh
they're gonna have to make some
decisions about what they want to
whether they want to keep her around so
that's at least a happy ending to that
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now I thank you for your
compliance it is somewhat appreciated